[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون نويهد
واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا
بالعناوين
واشنطن تقروا بالتضرر منظومات باتري جراء
هجوم روسيه على لندن تعتزم تشكيله تحالف
لتزويد 16 لاوكرانيا
تحريك مياه الازمه الليبيه الراكده اقاله
بشاغا ودعوات لتشكيل حكومه مصغره تجري
الانتخابات
سيناريو جوله الاعاده بانتخابات تركيا
الافضليه لاردوغان مع ترك الباب مفتوحا
لمفاجاه لدى المعارضه
بعد ان براه تقرير دورهام من علاقته
بروسيا في انتخابات 2016
ترامبيا توعد الديمقراطيين بثمن باهظ
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قال مسؤولون امريكي لشبكه سي ان
ان احد انظمه باتريوت للدفاع الجوي تعرض
لاضرار لكن لم يتم تدميره بعد هجوم
صاروخيز وقال المسؤول النوع شنطن لا تزال
تقيم حجم الضرر الذي اصاب النظام كما نقلت
تي ان ان عن مسؤولين قولهم ان اوكرانيا
بدات باستخدام صواريخ الصرم شادو المقدمه
من بريطانيا لدرب اهداف روسيه
في الاثناء اشارت رئاسه الحكومه
البريطانيه الى ان لندن تعتزم بناء تحالف
دولي لمساعده اوكرانيا في الحصول على
الطائرات مقاتله من طراز افسته عشر وشدد
رئيس الوزراء كريشيسوناك على اهميه ان
يزود الخلفاء اوكرانيا بمساعده امنيه
طويله الامد لضمان قدرتها على ردي هجمات
مستقبليه
[موسيقى]
من جانبه اكد وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
جيمس كليفر لضروره ان تظل بلاده والولايات
المتحده موحدتين لمواجهه التهديدات
النوويه لروسيا
اود التاكيد على ان زياره لواشنطن هي
للحديث مع الاداره الامريكيه وعرض وجهه
نظر بريطانيا بشان القضايا الرئيسيه بما
في ذلك التهديدات النوويه المحتمله لروسيا
وايران تم الحديث مع مشرعينا ومسؤولين
امريكيين من بينهم مايك ماكول لنقل وجهه
نظر بريطانيا للاداره الامريكيه ومجلس
الشيوخ لا تتفق الولايه المتحده والمملكه
المتحده دائما لكن يجب ان تظل متحدتين ضد
الاسلحه النوويه الروسيه والايرانيه
ميدانيا مرت عشره اشهر على اندلاع معركه
بخموت ولا تزال هذه المدينه تترنح بين
موسكو وكياف القوات الروسيه المدعومه
بمقاتل نيفاغنر لم تنجح رغم المحاولات
العديده في بسط السيطره الكامله على
المدينه فماذا لو كانت معركه بخموت مجرده
فخ اوكرانيا لاستنزاف القوات الروسيه
صحيفه
تعمدت اطاله المعارك في باخمت وذلك بهدف
انهاك القوات الروسيه كما نقلت الصحيفه
تصريحا للمتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه
يشير فيه الى التعمد اوكرانيا استدراج
القوات الروسيه الى ما وصفه بفخ بخموت
مضيفا ان هذه الخطه نجحت في اضعاف العدو
على حد قوله
[موسيقى]
اذا خطه اوكرانيا في بخمه اتت ثمارها بحسب
وولز جورنال وذلك نقلا عن مسؤولين
اوكرانيين فنجاحوا خطتك تمثل بدايه في
تمكن قواتها من استعاده اجزاء من المدينه
عقب هجوم مضاد مباغت الاكثر من ذلك هو ان
معركه بخمو تحولت الى صداع في راس موسكو
سيما بعدما تسببت في نشوب خلاف حاد بين
مجموعه وقاده الجيش الروسي يبدو ان مخاوف
موسكو تتصاعد معركه باخمد حيث رصد قيام
القوات الروسيه بتوزيع منشورات تحذر من
هجوم الاوكراني وسع النطاق في هذه الجبهه
انكم تقربوننا من انتصارنا العام وتقدمون
امكانيه استعداد مجموعات عسكريه اخرى
لتشارك في العمليات الهجوميه في باخموت ان
ممتن لكم وللجهود التي تبذلونها اتمنى لكم
العوده الى وحداتكم العسكريه احياء واصحاء
بعد استكمال كل مهامكم العسكريه المجد
لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وقبل ان اتابع الرئيس بايدن يلغي جوله
اسيويه كانت مقرره بعد قمه مجموعه السته
بسبب ازمه سقف الدين ونعود لمتابعه
الموضوع الاوكراني الروسي بقدر ما تتزايد
الشكوك حول قدرات موسكو القتاليه بقدر ما
تزداد القوه العسكريه للجانب الاوكراني
المنتشي بحزمات اسلحه جديده دول غربيه
عديده واصلت اغداق اوكرانيا بالاسلحه تاتي
في مقدمتها طبعا بريطانيا صحيفه تيليجراف
قالت ان لندن بصدد تجهيز كاب لتوجيه
الضربه القاضيه الى موسكوبي فبعد الزياره
الاخيره للرئيس الاوكراني
بات جليا ان الاخيره فتحت كل قنوات الدعم
لاوكرانيا فلندن اعلنت عن حزمه اسلحه
جديده الى كاب تتضمن مئات المسيرات
الانتحاريه
[موسيقى]
صحيفه تيليجراف كشفت ان بريطانيا تبذل كل
ما في وسعها لانهاء الحرب خلال السنه
الجاريه على اقصى تقدير لندن يبدو انها
تامل في استغلال الظرفيه الراهنه لمساعده
اوكرانيا على تشديد الخناق على روسيا
المتعثره في ساحه
ان الوقت مناسب لشن هجوم مضاد على روسيا
سيما وان الدبابات والمدرعات الغربيه باتت
متوفره لدى الجيش الاوكراني ما يعطيها
التفوق عسكريا
من كافه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه اهلا بك معنا سنبدا طبعا مع
تطورات الميدانيه موضوع استهداف هذا
الباتريوت نظام الباتريوت في هجوم الروسي
على فضلا عن تطورات الحاصله في باخموت
اوكرانيا تقول بانها تقدمت 20 كيلومترا
اين هذه المنطقه التي تقدمت فيها اوكرانيا
وما مدى اهميتها
مساء الخير ميسون يعني ابدا من نظام
باتريوت الذي قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
انها استطاعت ان تدمره وكذلك كما قلت قبل
قليل ان تم نشر تقرير لسي ان حول ان هذا
النظام قد تضرر بالفعل في ولكن طبعا بيان
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه اتى مغايرا لكل
ذلك صخرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه من
ادعاءات ما سمتها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
حول استهداف نظام باتريوت في العاصمه كيف
وقالت نصا ان طبعا هي حتى حتى السخريه لم
تكن بشكل مباشر ولم تذكر تحديدا الحادثه
ولكن قالت ان الناطق الرسمي باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه والاعلام الروسي هم السلاح
القوي والاقوى للدوله الروسيه الذي تستطيع
به ان تحارب العالم كله ان تسيطر على
العالم وهنا في اشاره لان هذه الادعات من
الروسي وكذلك من الناطق الرسمي باسم وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه انها كاذبه وانها غير
صحيحه كذلك اليوم سئل طبعا
وهو الناطق باسم سلاح الجو الاوكراني حول
هذه الحادثه وامتنع عن التعليق وقال لنا
اعلق على هذه على هذا الامر بالتحديد وذهب
وطبعا في الحديث الى امور اخرى حول عمليه
الاستهداف التي طالت العاصمه كيف طبعا
تحدثت عنها تطوراتها طبعا ارتفعت حصيله
الضربات الصاروخيه بعد ان كانت 18 صاروخا
في الساعات الاولى من صباح اليوم ووجهت
جميعها نحو العاصمه كيف ارتفعت الى 27
صاروخ استهدف مناطق قريبه لاستهدف خارقه
استهدف مخموت استهدف الاسكند
حذيفه ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول هذا
التضارب بالمعلومات روسيا تقول بانه لا
تقدم لاوكرانيا واوكرانيا تقول تقدمت اين
تقدمت هل على ضواحي باخمت ام بدات بالتقرب
لتدخل الى داخل باق موت
حتى يكون مفهوم ميسون جبهه باخمت ليست
مدينه باخموت جبهه باخبوتيه تتكون من
مخبوط افديفكا مارينكا وهذا الشريط حتى
منطقه قسطنطينه كهذه وهوورلف كل هذه تسمى
جبهه باخ مت وهنا لان القوات الروسيه التي
تسحب في هذه الجبهات في النهايه هي تتجه
نحو حصار هذه المدينه والدخول والسيطره
على هذه المدينه بالكامل لذلك كل هذه تسمى
جبهه اين تقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه تقدمت
في الاجنحه من اتجاه ماريكا
وايضا من اتجاه الشاص سافيار في الاجنحه
استطاعت ان تتقدم وان تستعيد السيطره على
عشره مواقع روسيه وان تسيطر على عشرين
كيلو متر وهذا رقم كبير يعتبر في هذه
الحرب اما القوات الروسيه فقد تقدمت من
العمق قليلا وهذا ما افادت به حتى وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه انا استطاعت ان تتقدم
في العقد داخل المدينه ولكن في الاجنحه من
خارج المدينه تقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه
حذيفه بايجاز لو سمحت موضوع الهجوم المضاد
لماذا
القاده الاوكرانيين يتحسسون من موضوع هذا
الهجوم المضاد دائما يقولون بان هجومنا لن
يتوقف لماذا تعطوا هذه الاهميه الى كلمه
الهجوم المضاد بايجاز
نعم باختصار شديد طبعا هذا لكي لا تقوم
يعني السلطات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان لا ترفع
السقف توقعات الجميع سواء كان الغرب شركاء
الغربيين المواطنين الاوكرانيين والعالم
الذي ينظر وينتظر هذا الهجوم المضاد لا
تريد ان ترفع سقف التوقعات حتى اذا في ارض
المعركه اذا استطعت ان تستعيد يعني عدد
كيلومترات اقل من المتوقع لا يكون ذلك
محبطا بالنسبه للشركاء وبالنسبه للجيش
ولقوات نفسها شكرا لك من كاذ مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل ونذكر مشاهدينا هذا الخبر
العاجل انباء عن اصابه عدد من اعضاء
السفاره الامريكيه في نيجيريا جره هجوم
اوكرانيا امام مفترق طرق حاسم في حربها ضد
روسيا
والفرصه قد تكون مواتيه لكيف من اجل حسم
المعركه صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه الوقت
مناسب لاوكرانيا لتوجيه ضربه موجعه لموسكو
فما هي العوامل التي ترجح كفتكيف العامل
الاول الانقسامات بين الجنرالات الروس
العامل الثاني تغيير بوتين للقاده
العسكريين على امتداد الحرب
العامل الثالث استنزاف القوات الروسيه في
معركه بخموت
العامل الرابع فشل حملات التجنيد الروسيه
في حسم الحرب
العامل الخامس زياده تدفق اسلحه الغرب الى
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا هناك ازمه اخرى داخل اروقه الحكم
في كاف تؤرق قيادتها وهي الفساد المدعي
العام في مكتب مكافحه الفساد والاكزندور
قال ان السلطات انفاذ القانون احتجزت رئيس
المحكمه العليا في البلاد في تحقيق رشاوه
بقيمه نحو 3 مليارات دولار نتابع
بسيط في هذا الوقت تم اعتقال رئيس المحكمه
العليا ويجري اتخاذ تدابير للتحقق من
الاشخاص الاخرين وتورطهم في الجريمه
الجنائيه
[موسيقى]
قبل ذلك صوت مجلس النواب الليبي بالاغلبيه
على ايقاف رئيس الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان
واحالته للتحقيق كما كلف مجلس النواب
الليبي وزير الماليه بالحكومه المكلفه
اسامه حماد بتسيير مهام رئاسه الحكومه
بالاضافه لوزاره الماليه وكان بشاغا كلف
في وقت سابق نائبه علي القطراني بتسيير
مهام مجلس الوزراء قبل ان تحجب الثقه عنه
[موسيقى]
وردا على سؤال للعربيه بشان ترشح قائد
الجيش خليفه حفتر وسيف الاسلام للانتخابات
المقبله قال المبعوث الامامي في ليبيا عبد
الله بتيلي انه لا يجب ان يستثنى احد من
العمليات الانتخابيه نتابع
ما المقاربه الامميه المتعلقه بشروط
الترشح هل من المفترض او من الضروري ان
يسمح للعسكريين ولوجوه النظام السابق بان
يترشحوا للرئاسيات ونقصد هنا بالتاكيد
خليفه حفتر سيف الاسلام القذافي وغيرهم من
الشخصيات بالتاكيد
ادركوا ان سمت قضاي جدليه بما في ذلك
معايير الترشح للانتخابات
ولكن فيما يخص بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم
في ليبيا
الانتخابات حتى تكون
ممثله لاراده الشعب الليبي ومن اجل توصل
الى استقرار بفضل هذه الانتخابات هذه
الانتخابات يجب ان لا تستثني احدا
ومشاهدينا طبعا هذه الاخبار العاجله ترد
الان من البيت الابيض يقول من قتل في
الهجوم على قفله الامريكيه في نيجيريا
ليسوا امريكيين اذا البيت الابيض يؤكد بان
من قتل في هذا الهجوم على القافله
الامريكيه في نيجيريا ليسوا امريكيين اي
جديد خلال ساعتنا الاخباريه اما الان
سنتابع في اخبار الساعه بعد لحظات الادعاء
الفرنسي يصدر مذكره توقيف دوليه بحق حاكم
مصرف لبنان المركزي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه قبل ان
ننتقل الى ملف تركيا نذكر بهذه الاخبار
العاجله الوارده الان من كييف حيث تم
اعلان حاله التاهب القصوى في العاصمه كيف
اي جديد سنتابعه مع زميلنا حذيفه عادل اذا
كان هناك اي تطور اما الان سنتحدث عن هذه
الانتخابات التركيه التي ستحصل بعد
اسبوعين حيث تترقب تركيا موعد الحسم
الثامن والعشرون من الشهر الجاري هو موعد
اجراء الجوله الثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسيه
في سابقه هي الاولى من نوعها في تاريخ
البلاد اردوغان الذي حصد النسبه الاعلى في
المرحله الاولى يرغب طبعا بالبقاء في
منصبه لولايه ثالثه بينما يطمح كليتشار
اوغلو الى خلق المفاجاه وازاحه اردوغان من
منصبه لكن طريقه لن تكون مفروشه بالورود
حيث سيكون الرجل مدعوا لتجاوز بعض العقبات
مجله فايننشل جزء رصدت ثلاث عقبات ستواجه
كليه جدار اوغلو خلال الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات العقبه الاولى تتمثل في ارهاق
الناخبين المعارضين بعد ان خيبت نتائج
الجوله الاولى توقعاتهم اما العقبه
الثانيه فهي غياب اجماع داخل المعارضه على
ترشيح كليتش وهو ما قد يؤثر مجددا على
وحده ناخذ المعارضه اما العقبه الثالثه
ودائما بحسب تايمز هي تضاؤل فرص حصول كلتش
دار اوبلو على اصوات المرشح سنان اوغان
والذي يميل اكثر الى معسكر اردوغان
[موسيقى]
في المقابل يبدو ان الرئيس اردوغان سيستمر
في قلب ما توقعته استطلاعاته الراي حيث
تبقى كفته ارجح في جوله الاعاده قياسا
طبعا بما حققه في الجوله الاولى وهو ما
اكدته ايضا
تفوق بنحو مليوني صوت على
وهو ما يعتبر فارقا مهما في عمليه التصويت
كما ان اردوغان احدث الفارق بعد نجاحه في
كسب اصوات سكان المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال عكس التوقعات تقول صحيفه لموض
بالفرنسيه كما تضيف الصحيفه نفسها ان
اردوغان يبدو قادرا على استماله اصوات
انصار سنان اوغان لانه يبدو ان طرفين اكثر
توافقا
في الثامن والعشرين من مايو سيتنافس مره
اخرى على رئاسه تركيا في جوله اعاده تحدث
للمره الاولى رجب طيب اردوغان من جانب
وكمال كلجدار اوغلو من جانب اخر وبينهما
يقف سنان اوغان فهل سيرجح كفه على اخرى
هاي اتفاق الى ان نكون مع تحالف ما فسيتم
التوقيع على اتفاق معهم ونضع الشروط التي
تضمن عدم تقديم اي تنازلات فيما يتعلق
بالحزب الديمقراطي المؤيد للاكراد لدينا
خطوطنا الحمراء لدعم اي مرشح كمكافحه
الارهاب واعاده اللاجئين لقد تحدثنا عن
هذه الشروط من قبل
تكمن قوه كليجدار اوغلو في جوله الاعاده
بقاعدته العلمانيه القوميه الثابته ستدعمه
مهما كلف الامر افكاره اقرب لكتله سنان
اوغان الانتخابيه ويدعم التوجه نحو نظام
حكم برلماني ما يعزز حضوره بين الشباب
اردوغان من جانبه لن يخسر من قاعدته
الانتخابيه اليمينيه الدينيه المحافظه
مهمته الحسابيه اسهل يحتاج فقط الى اعشار
لتجاوز عتبه الخمسين في المئه يبقى
الاقتصاد هو مفتاح صندوق الاقتراع من يقنع
الشباب والاصوات المتردده ان مستقبل تركيا
سيكون اكثر ازدهارا سيجد سبيله نحو كرسي
الرئاسه
لنفهم الصوره بشكل اوضح ينضم الي من انقره
مراسل العربيه زيدان اهلا بك معنا الكل
يترقب الثامن والعشرين من مايو وهذا الشهر
ولكن هل من مؤشرات على بدايه الحملات
الانتخابيه لكماله الاجتجار اوغلو وللر
رجب طيب اردوغان
نعم ميسون مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين
بالفعل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بدا
فعليا بالحمله الانتخابيه بقناه بمقابله
عفوا متلفزه
بثتها قناتي كنالدي وسين ان تركي مع
الرئيس التركي مساء هذا اليوم حاول خلالها
في هذه المقابله الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان يؤكد على ان على انه سيستمر
على نفس النهج الذي بدا فيه به في الجوله
الاولى من خلال الدعاء الانتخابيه لكن قال
انه لن يكون هناك تجمعات جماهيريه كبيره
لكن سيذهب الى مناطق الزلزال برفقه فاتح
اربكان زعيم حزب الرفاه من جديد يومي
السبت والاحد ويلتقي بالسكان هناك وانتقد
بشده
الاتهامات والانتقادات التي وجهتها قيادات
من حزب الشعب الجمهوري وسائل الاعلام
معارضه لسكان المناطق المتضرره من
الذين صوتوا للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وقال
ان وقال اردوغان ان مثل هذه التصرفات غير
لائقه لا سيما ان هؤلاء الاشخاص متضررين
وبحاجه الى الاحتضان
والمواساه بدل من الهجوم عليهم لانهم
صوتوا لحزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس
اردوغان لكن في هذه الاثناء ساقول ميسون
قبل ان اتحدث اكثر عن الدعايه الانتخابيه
وردت انباء الان ان قاده الطاوله السداسيه
اي تحالف الامه سيجتمعون غدا هنا في مقر
حزب الشعب الجمهوري الذي نقف امامه الان
لتقييم نتائج الانتخابات وتحيد وتحديد
عفوا خارطه طريق لجوله الاعاده اذا
الطاوله السداسيه ستجتمع للمره الاولى بعد
انتهاء الانتخابات او الجوله الاولى
والان البرلمان هو مع الرئيس تراجع طيب
اردوغان وحسبه فاصبحت هذه الفكره يعني غير
واقعيه هل من رؤيه جديده استراتيجيه لدى
المعارضه لتجذب فيها الناخبين في
الاسبوعين المقبلين
لا شك ان حاليا بدايه كمالك الجدار اوغلو
غير الفريق الاعلامي والفريق المسؤول عن
الحملات الدعائيه واقال يوم امس احد نوابه
بسبب الفشل كما قيل او طلب من نائبه
الاستقاله بالتالي نعم ربما نشهد تغيير في
التكتيك لكن موضوع التراجع عن وعده بتغيير
النظام البرلماني لا اعتقد انه يستطيع
الان ان يتراجع بشكل كامل وكبير عن هذا
المطلب والوعد الذي كان الشعار الرئيسي
لحملتها الانتخابيه لكن هناك انتقادات من
داخل حزب الشعب الجمهوري بضعف الدعايه
وعدم القدره في الرد على الدعايه المضاده
التي كانت تتهم طبعا الدعاء المضاده ونقصد
بها تحالف الشعب والرئيس اردوغان الذين
يتهمون حزب الشعب الجمهوري بانه يتلقى
دعما من حزب عمال الكردستانيه عبر التحالف
مع الشعوب الديمقراطيه وهذا ايضا ما اعاده
اليوم الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في خلال
مقابلته التلفزيونيه ولذلك ربما سيكون
التكتيك الانتخابي القادم محاوله الابتعاد
قدر الامكان عن
قدر الامكان او محاوله تفنيد قدر الامكان
هذه الاتهامات وذكرت صحافه المعارضه اليوم
بان حزب الشعب الجمهوري طلب من صلاح الدين
دمرداش الرئيس السابق لحزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي الديمقراطيه والمسجون حاليا في
قدرنا بتهام تتعلق بالارهاب طلب منه عدم
التغريد مجددا ودعم
كمالك الجدار اوغلو وايضا طلب التصويت
لهذا المرشح المعارضه في محاوله لتقليل
حده الانتقادات الموجهه من القوميين
تحديدا في كتله المعارضه لهذا التحالف مع
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي اذا كان معي بعض
الوقت هناك ايضا عوج انتهاء الوقت
سترسلها لنا وسنكون مع العواجل من زيدان
زنجلو من انقره شكرا لك ونحن ايضا سنذكر
بالاخبار العاجله الوارده من نيجيريا
الحكومه النيجيريه تقول بانه سبب او سبب
هذا الهجوم في وسط البلاد في نيجيريا
بمقتل ثلاثين شخصا وكان البيت الابيض قال
بانه الاشخاص الذين قتلوا في هذه القافله
بخلال هذا الهجوم ليسوا امريكيين
تويتر في الانتخابات التركيه
اوامر قضائيه تركيه طالبت تويتر بحجم
حسابات وتغريدات عده المحكمه التركيه طلبت
من المنصه منع الوصول لبعض الحسابات في
تركيا
فان قرات راى ان تلك الحسابات تشكل تهديدا
على النظام العام والامن القومي التركي
الشركه صاعت لبعض الاوامر وقدمت اعتراضا
على اخرى
صدرت بحقنا خمسه اوامر قضائيه وقدمنا
اعتراضات على اربعه منها لكن خبراء
يعتقدون ان المنصه اصبحت اكثر مرونه مع
الحكومات بعد استلام ماسك لادارتها
[موسيقى]
الان مشاهدينا الى الشان الامريكيه الرئيس
الامريكي دونالد ترامب وجد اخيرا صوتا
ينصفه وسط قائمه القضايا التي تلاحقه
الموضوع يتعلق بقضيه التدخل الروسي في
حمله ترامب الانتخابيه لعام 2016 الرئيس
الجمهوري السابق تحصل على صدقي براءته من
التهم الموجهه اليه فالمدعي العام المكلف
بالتحقيق في قضيه جون درهم اكد ان مكتبه
تحقيقات الفيدرالي فتح تحقيقه بناء على
معلومات غير مؤكده كما تهم درهم في
تقريرهم نهائي المحققين بالتحيز بل وتجاهل
غياب اي تبرير منطقي للادله التي تقود
الفرضيه حول مؤامره مسئومه بين ترامب
وموسكو
من واشنطن تنضم الي مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن ناديه بالبيسي ناديه اهلا بك معنا
الكل يتساءل الان كيف سيستفيد الرئيس
ترامب من هذا التقرير وخاصه في حملته
الانتخابيه
اهلا بك ميسون الرئيس ترامب سيحاول توظيف
نتائج هذا التحقيق ليقول بان هناك حمله
منظمه ضده من وزاره العدل ومن مكتب تحقيق
الفيدرالي منذ ان ترشح في الانتخابات
الاولى عام 2016 وبالتالي المؤيدين
والتابعين للرئيس ترامب
سيؤمنون بكل كلمه يقولها وهذا هو عباره عن
دليل جديد يؤكد بالفعل بان هناك عمليه
تسييس من قبل اشخاص ربما ينتمون لحزب
الديمقراطي عملوا في مكتب التحقيق
الفيدرالي لكن في نفس الوقت هناك من يرى
بانه نتائج هذا التحقيق اتت مخيبه للامال
لانه الرئيس ترامب نفسه ومؤيده كانوا
يطمحون بان يثبت بالفعل تورط اعضاء معينين
او افراد يعملون في الاف بي اي او في
وزاره العدل بشكل واضح يمكن ان يدينهم في
المحاكم بانهم استخدموا هذه المعلومات ضد
الرئيس ترامب لمنع ترشحي في الانتخابات
ايضا الجمهوريين كانوا عفوا الديمقراطيين
كانوا يرون بانه ربما يستطيع هذا التقرير
ان يثبت تورط الترامب مع روسيا بالتحديد
وان بالفعل كان هناك تواطئ لكن التقرير
اللي هو الذي حقق في التحقيق الاول الذي
تم في عهد روبوت مولر لم يثبت لهذا الطرف
او ذاك المعلومات التي يرونها لكن بكل
يعني بدون ادنى شك في حاله الانقسام التي
تعيشها واشنطن وفي ظل اجواء الانتخابات
القادمه سيتم استخدام هذا التقرير من كلا
الطرفين لكن اكثر من قبل الرئيس ترامب
اشكرك على كل هذه التوضيحات من واشنطن
مديره مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه
بالبيسي
[موسيقى]
هذا المشاهدين ترامب طبعا لم ينتظر طويلا
للتعليق على نتيجه التحقيقات التي طال
انتظارها حيث تواعد الديمقراطيين بثمن
باهض كما قال ان تحقيق درهم اثبت ان
اتهامات علاقته بروسيا اتت من خصوم سياسي
ثمن باهر توعد ترامبا الديمقراطيين بدفعه
بعد صدور نتائج تحقيق جون دوران الرئيس
الامريكي السابق قال ان مدير مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي السابق جيمس
والديمقراطيين يجب ان يحاسبوا على قضائهم
سنوات في التحقيق في التواطئ المزعوم بينه
وبين روسيا ياتي ذلك بعد ان اصدر المستشار
الخاص جون دورام تقريرا يقول ان التحقيق
حول علاقه ترامب وروسيا لم يكن ينبغي
اجرائه مطلقا هذه التحقيقات الديمقراطيه
اليساريه المتطرفه هي الاكثر اثاره
للاشمئزاز في تاريخ بلدنا انها وصمه عارك
سيكون الامر مسليا للغايه ولكن سنرى ما
سيحدث اذ اجرى المحققون تحقيقا سياسيا في
خضم انتخابات عام 2016 حول ما اذا كانت
حمله ترامب تواطئت مع روسيا لقلب النتيجه
التقرير انتقد مكتبه تحقيقات الفيدرالي
لفتح تحقيق كامل على اساس معلومات
استخباراتيه خام وغير محلله وغير مؤكده
فالسرعه التي فعل بها ذلك كانت خروجا عن
القاعده كما ذكر التقرير تطورات تاتي بعد
تحقيقات اجريت مع ترامب في منها وربما
ستخدم مصالحه قبيل انتخابات الرئاسه
وصراعه القوي مع الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
والديمقراطيين عموما بلال البشتين العربيه
منضم الينا اكل من المدعي العام الامريكي
السابق اهلا بكم معنا ما مدى اهميه هذا
التقرير وايضا هل هذه النتائج من الممكن
ان تحرج وزاره العدل
ياتي التقرير على ذكر اي شيء جديد وارى
بان السيد درم هو الذي يجب ان يشعر بالحرج
لتحليل
وخسارته لقضيتين في هذه في هذا الملف ولم
يتقدم باي مساله جديده
الفكره ان اف بي اي قد بدات بعمليه
التحقيق بسبب الرابط المزعوم بحمله الرئيس
ترامب مع الروسي وقد تبين لدرم بان لا
رابطا لذلك لا يوجد اي درابت وقد علمت
الاف بي اي بهذه المساله واخبرت اللجنه
الوطنيه من خلال حصولها على بعض الوثائق
والمستندات ومن ثم شرعت باجراء التحقيقات
بناء على ان
الحكومه الاسره لقد اخبرت الاف بي قبيل اي
معرفه
لدى عامه الجمهور حول ما حدث في هذا
الاختراق
وجورج باد بابلوس الذي كان
مستشار الامن القومي لترم قد اخبر ان
الدبلوماسيه الاستراليا في المملكه
المتحده
اشار الى ان الروس لديهم معلومات ورسائل
الكترونيه عن هيلر وعند مقارنه هذين
الملفين فقد يكون لديهم ادله
قويه للشروع في اجراء تحقيق وفي نهايه
الامر نعلم ان مولر لم يستطيعوا ان يقدم
قضيه يمكن التقاضي بها ضد اي شخص في حمله
للتامر او التواضع مع الروس لكن لكنه كان
لديه ادله
هل من الممكن ان نرى جلسات استماع يدعو
اليها رئيس المجلس الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
الهيئه الاستشاريه في مجلس النواب قد دعى
لعقد جلسات
بالشهاده السيد درهم قد تحدث في فتره غير
بعيده لذا قد نرى جلسه الاستماع هذا لكن
هذا لن يغير من طبيعه الامر فما من جديدا
في هذا التقرير وما من اشاره وردت فيه لم
نسمعه في السابق وكل والكل في اداره
ترمخانه كيتوقع حدوث هذا الامر فما من شيء
رئيسي البته شكرا
لكي السابق
[موسيقى]
ومتابعه مجددا للتطورات في اوكرانيا حيث
قلنا في اخبار عاجله منذ دقائق بانه اعلنت
السلطات حاله التاهب القصوى في العاصمه
سعيد نذهب الى مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
ليطلعنا على اسباب هذا الاعلان ماذا لدينا
من تفاصيل حذيفه طبعا حالته
واسعه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه الان من قبل
السلطات تم الاعلان عنها في العاصمه كيف
هي معظم الولايات الشرقيه والجنوبيه تم
اطلاق عدد من الصواريخ حتى الان لم يتم
تحديد العدد الكامل للصواريخ التي تم
اطلاقها نحو الاراضي الاوكرانيه قبل حوالي
دقيقتين فقط تم الاعلان عن خمس صواريخ
وبعد ذلك تم الاعلان عن مزيد من الصواريخ
الان هنالك تاكيد لوصول في مدينه نيكا
لايف وانفجار وكذلك في زبروجه وانفجار نحو
العاصمه حتى الان لم يتم الاعلان اذا ما
كانت تم تدمير الصواريخ التي تتوجه نحو
العاصمه ام لا ولكن كان هنالك خمسه صواريخ
في الطريق نحو العاصمه اتوقع طبعا ان يكون
قد تم تدميرها حتى الان تقول السلطات انه
تم اطلاق
الصواريخ من البحر الاسود من حاملات
الصواريخ في البحر الاسود الان ايضا
هنالكم معلومه عن ان هنالك صواريخ تتجه
نحو الغربه الاوكراني وكذلك نحو العاصمه
هذه المعلومات تريد الى الان بينما اتحدث
اليك يعني كل يعني الان هنالك حاله تاهب
جوي واسعه الاوكرانيه على كل حال
دائما سنكون معك حذيفه لتطلعنا على كل
التطورات الحاصله اكتفي بهذا القدر الان
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا لك
الان سنذهب الى لبنان حيث بات حاكم مصرف
لبنان المركزي رياض سلامه مطلوبا للعداله
القرار اصبح ساري المفعول باصدار القاضيه
الفرنسيه المكلفه بالتحقيق في امواله
وممتلكاته في اوروبا مذكره توقيف دوليه
بحقه
ويشتبه المحققون الفرنسيون في ان السلامه
كما اصولا عقاريه ومصرفيه عبر عمليات
احتياليه كما يعتبر القضاء الفرنسي ان
سلامه استخدام اموال عامه لبنانيه خلال
توليه اداره مصرف لبنان طوال ثلاثه عقود
رياض سلامه الذي تغيب عن جلسه استجواب
كانت مقرره في باريس لم يتاخر في الدفاع
عن نفسه وقال ان اصدار مذكره توقيف دوليه
في حقه خرق لابسط القوانين مضيفا انه
سيطعن في هذا القرار
في اخبار الساعه بعد لحظات الجيش السوداني
يقول انه لا يتحمل مسؤوليه نهب مقر سفارات
ويتهم الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه سنتابع
من السودان حيث قال اللواء نبيل عبد الله
الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني ان الظروف
الحرب منعت قوات الامن في توفير الحمايه
اللازمه لمقر البعثات الدبلوماسيه عبد
الله اتهم قوات الدعم السريه بمهاجمه مقر
دبلوماسيه ونهب ممتلكاتها واتلاف ما فيها
من مستندات واضاف الناطق باسم الجيش
السوداني ان ادله اتهام قوات الدعم السريع
بشنه تلك الهجمات تستند الى بلاغات تقدمت
بها السفارات فضلا عن روايات شهود عيان
[موسيقى]
وعلى الصعيد الميدانيه تجددت الاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في منطقه دار
الرياض في الخرطوم قبل ذلك اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء ارتفاع عدد القتلى المدنيين جراء
الاشتباكات الى
822 شخصا وقالت النقابه في بيان لها ان
استمرار اشتباكات ادى الى سقوط مزيد من
الضحايا في العاصمه الخرطوم وعدد من
الولايات
[موسيقى]
الى باكستان ففي اعقاب اعمال شغب على
خلفيه اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان ابدت لجنه الامن القومي تضمنها مع
القوات المسلحه بعد ان طالتها اعمال تخريب
وعبدا الاجتماع تاييده لبيان الجيش الذي
توعد منها جموم مقر راسه
اجتماع للمطبخ الامني للحكومه الباكستانيه
بمشاركه القيادتين السياسيه والعسكريه
الاجتماع جدد التنديد باعمال الشغب
والتخريب التي طالت منشات ومرافق خاصه
وعامه من بينها مرافق التابعه للجيش
متواعدا مخطط ومنفذ الهجمات باجراءات
صارمه تنجو
اجتماع لجنه الامن القومي يعبر عن تضامنه
مع الجيش الباكستاني ويدين هذه الحوادث
سياخذ القانون مجراه وسنتخذ الاجراءات
القانونيه والاداريه اللازمه لمنع تكرار
ما جرى لن تتم معاقبه اي شخص دون مبرر
لكننا لن نتهاون مع المذنبين ممن خططوا
وحرضوا على التخريب هم بلا شك مذنبون
بالارهاب
عمران خان نفاي صله له ولحزبه باحداث
الشعب والتخريب التي تلت اعتقاله متهما في
المقابل عناصر في الامن بافتعالها لتبرير
ما وصفها بالحمله الامنيه ضد قاده ونشطاء
حزبه داعيا الى تشكيل لجنه تحقيق مستقله
ومجددا دعوه انصاره للتظاهر
لقد حان الوقت للتضحيه من اجل الحريه
الحقيقيه ومقاومه ما يقوم به بعض الاف من
عناصر الشرطه فعندما يرفض الشعب هذه
القسوه كما رفض النيل من الدستور والقضاء
ويطالب باختيار ممثله عندها ستصبحون
احرارا اكسروا صنم الخوف وعندما ادعوكم
للنزول للشارع تظاهروا سلميه لنيل حقوقكم
وحرياتكم
وفيما يواجه عمران خان وقاده حزبه قائمه
طويله من القضايا والبلاغات اصدر مجلس
النواب قرارا للتضامن مع الجيش وادانه
مرتكبي اعمال الشغب فيما نفى مسؤولون
حكوميون وجود اي خطه لحظر حزب الانصاف من
العمل السياسي ويرى مراقبون ان رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان امام خيارات
صعبه اما الرضوح لضغوط الحكومه ومواجهه
الاتهامات ضده او استمرار التصعيد
والمواجهه وتحمل اي عواقب قد تطال قاده
حزمه وربما تماسك عبد الرحمن المزيني
العربيه اسلام اباد في شان السوداني الدعم
السريع ينفي تعرض البعثات الدبلوماسيه في
الخرطوم لهجمات ويقول انها تحت حمايته
نتابع قال الرئيس الفرنسي
غير المقبول بحق ابن شقيق زوجته على هامش
التظاهرات ضد اصلاح نظام التقاعد امر لا
يمكن وصفه مضيفا ان هذه الافعال تعد غير
مقبوله
ختام اخبار الساعه الى العناوين
وعشان تنتقروا بتضرر منظومات باتريو جراءه
هجوم روسيه على كياف ولندن تعتزم تشكيله
تحالف تزويد افسته عشر لاوكرانيا
تحريك المياه الازمه الليبيه الراكده قالت
بشاغه ودعوات لتشكيل حكومه صغيره تجري
الانتخاب تجري الانتخابات
سيناريوهات جوله الاعاده بانتخابات تركيا
الافضليه لاردوغان مع ترك الباب مفتوحا
لمفاجاه للمعارضه وبعد ان براه تقرير
دورهام من علاقته بروسيا في انتخابات 2016
ترامب يتوعد الديمقراطيين بثمن باهض
اشكر لكم في المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات